hey everyone it's Sarah the registered
nurse rn.com and in this video I'm going
to be covering coarse crackles first
let's listen to some audio of what
coarse crackles may sound like
now how do you know that your hearing
coarse crackles well you want to pay
attention to their timing coarse
crackles tend to occur around the
beginning of inspiration but they can
extend into expiration and they tend to
be longer than fine crackles also their
pitch is low and they are discontinuous
in addition they tend to be located in
the large Airways such as the bronchi
and they have specific defining
characteristics these coarse crackles
tend to sound like a gurgling or
bubbling sound that is not cleared with
coughing and again let's listen to this
audio of course crackles
foreign
well it tends to occur whenever patients
breathe air in to partially blocked
Airways like those large Airways such as
the bronchi that are filled with fluid
or really thick mucus so whenever you're
trying to think of lung conditions that
will cause this sound think of lung
conditions that present with fluid or
thick mucus and these conditions could
include heart failure due to pulmonary
edema which is fluid in the lungs or
severe cases of pneumonia or
bronchiectasis which is a chronic lung
condition where the bronchi are enlarged
due to Chronic lung disease for example
like cystic fibrosis or infections that
result in mucus secretions okay so that
wraps up this video on coarse crackles
and if you'd like to watch more videos
in this respiratory series you can
access the link in the YouTube
description below